you are playing against Sheriff right so  it's not very likely that your opponent  is just going to trade Queens with you  in this position uh  and if you if you consider other moves  for a second instead of Queen takes D7  here you will come to the conclusion  that you're about to  to lose but on the other hand you know  maybe he understood that he is losing  getting crushed anyway yeah and then he  wanted beautifully  beautifully but yeah I don't know uh he  will go into the books though with this  with this particular conclusion he will  definitely be featured in  uh in books  yeah Alexa starts with a great win  they're definitely okay and not not  really surprising because when we saw  the opening it was clear that there will  be some some terrible tactical idea and  and some Massacre  urbanist he went on two